Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is 2192. David P I had Slash
have covered as many of you know, every
day I've been doing a little bit better,
my voice a little bit stronger every
day. And our friend Eric from Mass,
who has been warning me, I'm going to end up
in prison because of the things I said about
the vaccine has a new message for me. And
the message is the vaccine gave me COVID,
apparently on a very long delay. Take a listen.
Speaker 5: Hey, David, I saw your video. You
look pretty rough, man. You got COVID from the
vaccine. You know, 80 and 90%. The Washington
Post came out and said, uh, people got. Over the
from people who are not vaccinated against COVID.
Speaker 2: Yeah, uh.
Speaker 1: I don't know what
what he's talking about, but. Okay.
Speaker 5: Yeah. I hope you
feel better, but it doesn't have to get better.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I am feeling better. And, you
know, I said at the beginning of the week. I got
emails from people saying, David, this is proof
the vaccine doesn't work because you got COVID
anyway. And other people who wrote in and said
you should be glad you were vaccinated because
you on average probably had a milder case. Now
being beyond it, hopefully barring any kind of
rebound. If I really zoom out. I was very sick
for about 26 hours. And it does seem completely
plausible and in line with the science that the
reason I was really only down in bed for 26
hours would be that I received this Bivalent
booster targeted specifically to Ahmed KRON just a
couple of months ago. Now, listen, I'm right with
everybody when we talk about vaccination and we
say, hey, you know what, we vaccinate kids against
hep B and they don't get happy and we vaccinate
kids against measles and they don't get measles.
Yes. At some point, I hope and believe it
obviously is the goal to get to a COVID vaccine
that is like that. But absent that, something that
people end up hospitalized with and people die
with, and at the end of the day, I was really
sick with a fever 26 or 28 hours during which
I watched four World Cup games and one movie.
Completely plausible that that is indeed because
of the vaccine. Obviously, this is a sample of
one. I can't go back and have the COVID without
the vaccination to see how bad it would have
been. I also have no interest in doing that.
We have a voicemail number. I'm sorry, we have
a bonus show today. That was the voicemail. We
have a bonus show today. We're going to talk
about the Taylor Swift Ticketmaster fiasco.
Interesting story about monopoly power. Big tech.
So many different things. We'll talk about that.
Cherokee Nation wants to send a delegate to the
House of Representatives. We will talk about the
context in the history of such representatives.
And Madison Cawthorn, outgoing, failed member of
Congress. Madison Cawthorn has been directed
to pay a fine for an improper cryptocurrency
purchase. What is it all about? What did he do?
What did he say? Why does he have to pay a fine?
And does the House have the authority to make him
pay such a fine? All of those stories when I am
joined by producer Pat on today's bonus show. Sign
up. Join Pacman dot com. It is a beautiful thing.